Los Angeles a city famous for its
freeways is now one step closer to
building a major thoroughfare just for
wildlife an overpass estimated the cost
eighty eight million dollars is in its
final design phase it will allow
mountain lions and other animals to roam
more freely and officials say it could
actually help them avoid extinction this
bridge would be the first of its kind
near a major city and the largest in the
world Carter Evans went to where the
wild things are to see why it's so
important mountain lions and other wild
animals have lived in the heart of Los
Angeles for centuries but the freeways
that were built to connect people ended
up isolating wildlife Beth Pratt is with
the National Wildlife Federation what
most of them do is they come to the
freeway and turn around hoping to
preserve mountain lions and other
species officials are in the final
design stage for a crossing over one of
LA's busiest freeways
the 101 this is not gonna look like a
standard overpass no these are beautiful
they're not just bridges these are
vegetated landscapes because the animals
have to feel safe the overpass would
stretch 200 feet over ten lanes of
highway and provide big cats coyotes and
other creatures better access to not
just food but also potential mates we
don't provide connectivity they can't
get dates outside their family so they
are at risk of going extinct so they
understand what dating life is like in
LA yeah you know like all of us the four
or five divide has killed many a romance
the more mountain lions can come into
contact with one another the greater the
genetic diversity and the healthier the
population seth riley is a wildlife
ecologist for the National Park Service
we just need a few to make it across and
reproduce to make a big difference
genetically we've seen actually animals
south of 101 have some of the lowest
genetic diversity of any population
anywhere in the West since the National
Park Service started tracking mountain
lions in 2002 18 have died trying to
cross freeways and other secondary roads
without the overpass animals have been
forced to take risks or get created
Mountain Lion was it that made it
through here so it was p60 for this
image captured P 64 coming out of a
drainage pipe last year found this long
dark tunnel that unfortunately isn't
great in terms of a wildlife crossing in
general so far the National Wildlife
Federation has raised more than 13
million dollars from private donors and
they're confident they'll raise the
remaining 50 to 60 million completion is
set for 2023 so this is a pretty large
area how do we know that animals will
find their way to this one tiny bridge
so we put up a sign crossing that way no
you know what's great about wildlife
crossings is the science is really well
established where we have the advantage
from some of these other crossings is
this as it they're already trying to
cross here what I love about it too
we're saving mount lines we're
reconnecting an ecosystem but we're
gonna inspire the world that many people
are gonna drive under this and know
what's possible in LA if la can do it
nobody else has an excuse for CBS this
morning Carter Evans Agoura Hills
California